Instead of awarding damages,
courts may order the breaching party to actually perform its promise.
This is known as specific performance and it's the subject of today's lecture.
Uh,
today we're going to be talking about Northern Indiana public service company
versus Carbon County coal decided by the seventh circuit in 1986 in that case,
Northern Indiana public service company or Nipsco entered into a 20 year
contract to buy about one and a half million tons of coal from Carbon County
every year for 20 years at a price of $24 per ton subject to a price escalation
clause.
The contract price eventually escalated $44 per time,
but because of a large drop in the price of oil,
Nipsco was able to buy electricity at prices below the cost of generation.
With Cole Nipsco,
the plaintiff sought declaratory judgment that it was excused from the contract.
Carbon County counterclaimed for specific performance.
The Trial Court denied specific performance and enter to a jury verdict for,
uh,
for the defendant for $181 million.
Both parties appealed and the instant court affirmed.
The central issue is this was carbon county and titled to specific performance
in an opinion written by Judge Richard Posner who as I've mentioned before is
known for his economic analysis of law.
The court held that Carbon County was not entitled to specific performance and a
four and affirmed the damage awarded by the trial court pose near explained that
quote like other equitable remedies specific performance is available only if
damages are not adequate remedy and there's no reason to suppose them inadequate
here.
Basically the test is a,
you don't give spe specific performance if awarding dollars would be sufficient
to compensate.
Further,
Posner noted that Carbon County did not even argue that the award was not a
reasonable estimate of damages.
Rather,
it complained that without specific performance,
the miners employed by carbon county will lose their jobs.
Posner dismiss this reasoning saying that quote,
since the employees are not parties to the contract,
their losses are irrelevant.
Indeed.
Continued poster with his characteristic economic tilt,
quote specific performance would be improper as well and as a necessary here
because it would force the continuation of production that has become
uneconomical and continuing to produce coal under compulsion of an order of
specific performance would impose costs on society greater than the benefits
poster.
Also predicts that were he to grant specific performance,
the miners would lose their jobs anyway because carbon county would merely use
the threat of specific performance as a bargaining chip in order to extract a
larger settlement payment.
From Nipsco note that Posner's argument here is an application of the coast
there,
whether or not the court grants specific performance,
the efficient economic outcome is the closing of the mind and the coast there.
I'm suggests that it's going to occur whether or not specific performance does
or ordered and the parties will simply negotiate how to split the economic
savings
as this case makes clear specific performance.
There's only a last resort available only if damages,
uh,
provide an inadequate remedy.
In other words,
the law does not actually require a promise or to keep his promise as long as
the promise or is willing to compensate the injured promise with cash.
To paraphrase Oliver Wendell Holmes,
a contractual duty is the duty to perform or pay damages.
Those who believe it is a moral to break the promise may find this troubling.
The laws ethically neutral approach to breach of contract is often justified by
the theory of efficient breach under the theory of a bridge of efficient breach
of promise or should be allowed to breach his promise as long as he compensates
the primacy because of promise or will only tend to breach when the benefits
from her breach or greater than the promises benefit from the promise or his
performance.
The theory of efficient breach can be illustrated with an example.
Suppose Acme contracts to sell a machine to big company for $100,000 the machine
is worth $110,000 to big.
Who plans to use it to manufacture widgets.
However,
prior to the delivery date,
custom manufacturing offers to buy the machine from acne for $120,000.
Instead of delivering the machine to big his promise,
acme sells the machine to custom manufacturing for 120,000.
What are bigs damages?
Well,
Acme must pay big $10,000 in damages.
The value of the machine to big less the price it would have to pay even after
paying damages.
Acme who received $20,000 more by breaching still comes out ahead.
This is considered an efficient breach because the machine was ultimately sold
to custom manufacturing the party that apparently valued the machine the most.
However,
there is a potential flaw in using the theory of efficient breach to justify
specific performance for the sale of the good.
If instead of damages,
big was granted specific performance,
acme would have to sell the machine to big for $100,000.
But acme would then have an incentive to bargain,
uh,
with big to modify Acmes performance duty.
Posner would predict that big would be willing to pay acme somewhere between 10
and $20,000 in order to avoid.
The courts order to inefficiently perform.
Let's review.
Today we learned that courts favor monetary damages over a specific performance.
Generally,
specific performance is available only if monetary damages are an inadequate
remedy.